(light music)
- [Narrator] On the sandy
shores of the Florida Keys,
sea turtles are laying their eggs
but a threat is looming
for these gentle creatures.
The Caribbean climate has become
increasingly unpredictable
as rising sea levels cripple the beaches
where these turtles annually nest.
- They come back to their natal beaches
so animals that were born here
are coming back to this
very little spit of land
in order to lay their own eggs.
If the beach goes away, they may not be
as flexible to use another beach.
- [Narrator] Dr. Kristen Hart
and her team of researchers
are working around the clock,
tagging and tracking these turtles
in an effort to protect their future.
- They're in peril, they do need help
and we're trying to figure
out where the problems are.
(light music)
We are here on East Key in
Dry Tortugas National Park.
We are about 70 miles west of Key West
and we're in the Gulf of Mexico.
There are seven islands,
we're on one of the smallest
but one of the densest
turtle nesting beaches.
Some of them are right
on top of each other,
a foot away from each other,
this is an almost completely marine park
and the turtles come up and
grace us with their presence.
It's pretty amazing to
see these animals up close
and personal with them,
and we get right in there.
Generally sea turtles date back
to the time of the dinosaurs
so it's 200 million years of evolution.
Our study was the first
to really concentrate
on the Dry Tortugas turtles.
Our goals are to try to determine patterns
of movement and habitat use,
to figure out where they might go.
(light music)
All these points are either
sightings or capture points.
When we first started working here,
we realized that we could dip
net juvenile green turtles.
I had done this in the Everglades
and out here the water is much more clear,
we can pursue them in the
flats and shallower areas.
She's coming up.
The bigger turtles out here,
we do what's called a rodeo
capture, or also turtle jumping.
They're usually 10 or 15 feet down
but when they need to come get a breath,
they're coming up to the surface
and so that's when the
diver meets them down there
and you basically get your
hands sort of on the rear,
right behind the head, and
you get the animal pointed up.
I've got him.
It's a team effort,
once we get them on board the boat
we'll do a standard workup,
which includes measuring them,
weighing them, taking blood
samples, tissue samples,
there's a lot of
questions that we can ask,
even just about how healthy they are
and how healthy then are the
resources that they're using.
We also fix devices on them
to track their movement,
so we've used acoustic
telemetry, radio telemetry
and then satellite tracking,
so we're learning a lot
about their movement paths
and their areas of residence.
(light music)
They've been around the globe
but they're hard-wired to
come back to the very place
where they were born
to lay their own eggs.
If an animal was born on East Key,
she'll come back to East Key,
she's not gonna go use Loggerhead Key
or one of the other Keys here.
(light music)
We all take turns, every 30 minutes,
walking around this beach in particular.
It takes about 10 minutes to walk around.
If they nest, we let them nest
and mark off where the nest
is and then we work her up,
just like the same workup we
would do with a little turtle.
She's corralled in a box
cause they can be 400 pounds
and they're very powerful
and they'll do that about
every two weeks during a season.
And when we get recaptures
that's really exciting,
cause you know the animal still
survived, wherever she went.
- [Narrator] In order for
turtles to lay their eggs,
the conditions have to be just right.
Ideally, they'll encounter
high tides, dark beaches
and warm sea surface temperatures,
otherwise they'll do
something called a false crawl
in which a turtle will make
their way onto the beach
only to turn back around.
- We don't really know
why they'll false crawl
but something isn't right.
Maybe they're not feeling contractions,
maybe the conditions just
aren't right at that spot,
maybe they dig and they
hit a piece of coral
or a root, or something like that.
- [Narrator] And false crawls
could become more frequent.
Rising sea levels reduce the
amount of available beach space
and rising temperatures
can drastically affect
sand temperature.
Studies show that cooler nest temperatures
produce more males, while warmer nests
generally produce females.
- With sea level rise and climate change,
they're threatened.
I think we're a little more concerned
about their trajectory
of their population,
cause it's generally not
good for the turtle.
(light music)
We've learned a lot about
these Dry Tortugas turtles
and it really is valuable to me to know
that they value the research
that we're contributing,
we're answering questions
that are important,
that haven't been asked before.
It's definitely demanding,
but at the same time I think
it's one of the most rewarding
things we could ever do.
There aren't many people allowed
on this little patch of land,
so I feel very privileged
to be able to play a role in
figuring these turtles out
and being in this very special place.